[Music]
hello and welcome to worlds apart
freedom of speech is one of the pillars
of democracy and also the one that in
the West is perceived as being in
greatest peril with the left claiming
that it has become a vehicle co-opted by
the right to spread hate and the right
dividing the left as sinister snowflakes
answers just what are the boundaries of
free speech to discuss that I'm now
joined by British activist Tommy
Robinson mr. Robinson it's good to see
you thank you very much for coming over
it's good to be seen now what brings you
to Russia I'm giving a presentation
tomorrow to explain the history and the
dangers of what's called grooming which
is more of a rape dad now speaking about
the topic of your talk correct me if I'm
wrong it's titled the rape of Britain I
know that you are prone to
generalizations but isn't that too broad
and too threatening of a statement no
it's not and prone to generalizations I
say first in my rape and discussion I
talk about Islam not Muslims in general
not talk about Muslims in general
Islam's an idea it's a book it's an idea
to criticize that I did practice by
Muslims but if I criticize Christianity
I'm not in sewing or picking for every
Christian I'm picking fault at the idea
so when we see the rate levels that
we've seen in our country and from a
population Muslim males make up 2.2
percent of the British population they
are responsible for 84 percent of the
convictions of this talk this type of
rape and what you have to ask the
question is why which we're not allowed
to watch well I think you pointed out
very specifically that it's this type of
rape and I suggest that we talk in more
detail about various kinds afraid but
before we do that when I hear when I
heard the title of your talk the rape of
Britain the immediate association that I
God was with the book The Rape of
Nanking it's a very famous book
describing six weeks in 1937 during
which the Japanese forces killed
at least 200,000 civilians and raped
20,000 at least 20,000 Chinese women
even with those races even with those
cases that you're trying to highlight
the statistics the rape statistics and
in Britain is nowhere near that in fact
if you look at the statistics Britain is
pretty much on par without the developed
countries 19,000 children in 2018 were
groomed by these gangs in one year so
when you talk about the rape of brim if
I give you the statistics we have a town
called Telford as a 1.8 percent Muslim
population 1000 children were raped by
those gangs five have been murdered in
that town alone when you take the 1.8
percent and you take away under-16s and
you take away over 65s
there's only 956 Muslim men in that town
the police the police have identified
200 in operation chalice that means that
21 percent of the Muslim men in that
town have been involved in the rape and
torture of our daughter to them as
Muslims but you know I'm not a Muslim
myself but I'm married to a Muslim okay
and I know for a fact that Islam imposes
very strict limits on extramarital sex
not to mention rape I mean those people
that are convicted of raping anyone they
would not be considered Muslims by Islam
why do you have to tie to if you come
and see if you if my presentation I give
tomorrow proves all of this
categorically proves it it says four
times in the Quran outside of your four
wives you can take wherever the right
arm possesses sexual slaves and I have
on my video I will have I will have
Imams and experts confirming what that's
means sexual slaves I also look at
witness testimonies from the victims and
I also listen to what the perpetrators
said in court so the men when they were
sentenced in Rotherham all of them
chanted Allah Akbar
the comments they make were about you
know if while we're on the grooming
scandal one of the girls they murdered
the day before he murdered a sent his
friend a message saying he's sending
that Kafar to hell before being
non-muslim the standing of Islam but I'm
sure you would agree that they're
hundreds of thousands millions of
Muslims who would be justice not revolt
it got the idea for a girl or you know a
boy a child being raped as their and
by referring to them as Muslims you are
also tainting those individuals because
they subscribe to the Muslim faith as
well I'm not painting them what I'm
saying is if 84% of convictions and
Muslim males from two point three
percent why do you think those where you
got this statistics from because that's
the best from acquit that's from the
Quilliam Foundation which is a Muslim
anti-extremism think time I mean the
last time I check British police
actually does not keep track of the or
does not release the ethnicity or the
religious affiliation of the
perpetrators out of the 404 so far men
who have been convicted for this type of
to this type of free but I mean as
cousins in most countries developed
countries and the UK is no exception
here the rape the majority of freaks are
perpetrated by the locals and in the
British case it would be white males are
you saying that a British girl being
raped by her British neighbour is
somehow less offensive than a British
girl being raped by her no math Nick
Peck is not no it's not what I'm saying
is that do you have type 1 and type 2 in
the UK that's how it's known type 1 is
where gangs of men who know each other
they usually related in most of these
cases in every town and city brothers
cousins work colleagues that has never
happened in the UK out out of those
convictions nought point 5 percent have
a British name nor point 5 percent now
when you were talking about type 2
pedophilia that is loan pedophile
sharing their sexual fantasies with
other lone pedophiles via the internet
or grooming in that process them
literally exclusively that is white but
that's because we live in an 87% white
country that hasn't been covered up what
we have seen for example in Manchester
the young go was injected of heroin in
2003 she was 15 years old she was
murdered by a 50 year old Muslim male
who had been who had been grooming her
and raping her
the police launched an investigation
okay they identified the perpetrators
then in 2005 : cramp porn shut down the
investigation okay he closed it he was
rewarded by the British state a CB the
biggest award you can get for hiding
this
then we had the investigation in Telford
where where local politicians blocked an
investigation we've seen it we believe
that local authorities could be covering
that out of political correctness but
this in every town and city if it was
one town or one or two but we have seen
grooming gangs operating in 44 cities
and we've seen every one of them in all
countries and in many countries Russia
for example prostitution rings or human
trafficking rings are run by ethnically
homogeneous groups Britain is no
exception here I know for a fact that
there are many ethnic Russians involved
in human trafficking in the Western
Europe perhaps even the in the UK but
they're doing that not because they're
Russians they're doing that because
they're criminals why are you portraying
it as a religious issue rather than a
criminal in my presentation tomorrow
you'll hear from the victims so the
victims say it's raised from religious
the perpetrator says racial religious
religious the Koran and the scripture
supports and justifies these actions
against simply not true it is true and
unfortunately when we're talking about
we're not talking about sexual
gratification here we're talking about
one young girl 12 years old had a tongue
nailed to a table another young girl
they hit they heated up an iron rod with
the letter M and they scolded it on
their bomber eleven years old because
she was the property of Mohammed these
girls are being tortured I can take any
book Bible and use it as a pretext for
the most horrible crimes if we are you
actually believing that those are the
people of faith I'm saying they're
following the teachings of Mohammed
Mohammed had sexual slaves Mohammed
legitimize using that in a literal sense
I mean look at tomorrow is what the
victims were told so I give the
statement we can have sex with you once
you start your period okay then I
question let's have a look whether that
is Islamic for example in Pakistan they
tried to ban underage marriage and it
was found by the ideology of Islam that
it was Una's la m'q why would marry in a
child and having sex over a child be
under Islamic we've had 30 children
married in the borough of London
large religion and there are many
strains within Islam and some
interpretations of Islam are indeed
horrendous as are some interpretations
of the Bible my problem with that is
that again you would agree that there
are many good people and more Muslims
because your alleys they could be the
ones who would be looking after those
potential predators but you are
alienating them by suggesting that their
faith is directly responsible for the
crimes of those individuals Boko Haram
give justification Boko Haram a
terrorist organization in Nigeria they
give justification for kidnapping girls
and enslaving them saying it's quoted by
Allah Mohammed commands you Isis done
exactly the same Isis are taking slaves
Boko Haram are taking slaves and across
every town and city in my country
they're taking slaves my worry is on if
we're worried about me offending some
people with my speech a generation of my
you are a self-described British patriot
right yes and I'm sure you know that the
British legacy in some countries it's
pretty important I mean take the
colonial crimes in Africa in India
before for example just as recently as
the 1950s the British forces used rape
and castration to put down uprisings in
Kenya they paved compensation to the
victims a few years back would it
justify me to throw around labels like
British killers or Anglican rapists at
anyone who has any relation to the
British identity I don't live in the
past and I'm not throwing those
accusations at every single Muslim so so
that's it for me it's an irrelevant
point you you are evading my question
would would that justify me calling
anyone who has any relation to the
British state because it was the British
Army the British forces who were
perpetrating those crimes not just
individuals but actually the state
institution that authorized this kind of
treatment of people would that justify
me throwing that kind of labels to at
anyone who is connected to the British
state no it wouldn't but I'm not
throwing those accusations at anyone
that's connected you were referring to
them as Muslim Reapers they were Muslim
rapists but how is it different from the
British rapist then because these men
are Muslims
they're rapists and they're raping young
children and those men were also British
and they were with you labeling those
people who commit crimes as British
rapists we are talking about
generalizations here in rows I'm talking
about Islam people have to get the
understanding that Islam is an idea and
Mohammed is its founder and we have a
right to criticize and look at his life
because when you look at his life and
you see the pillaged he murdered he
raped his wife if you understand say the
bedlam the best limb school attack was
what woke me up that was my moment the
train I don't consider those people
Muslim at all I mean don't you don't you
don't bear with the bedlam school attack
as with there was a Jewish tribe and
they surrendered to Mohammed yeah and
this is in their Scripture sorry Bukhari
this is in opinion spectacle but you
have to understand the relevance of it
this is why it's so relevant which I'll
show tomorrow because when the Taliban
took children in Pakistan in peshwa when
they put with Matt what Muhammad done
when the Jews surrendered he pulled
their pants down whoever it's had pubic
hairs was beheaded as somebody who's
reported from a lot of front lines
especially from the Muslim countries I
know that we're killing Muslims Muslims
exactly good people that I identify with
for some reason you are only identifying
Muslims to be the bad people identifying
is that these attacks 1,400 years later
they used the scripture to justify the
attack no what I'm saying is when we see
and and no one can explain it and we're
not even allowed to ask the question
what I want to do is prevent another
generation of our daughters being raped
and if we have to are serious questions
to investigate why these Muslim males
feel that they can do that why brothers
in one group of them were to celebrate
Eid they kidnapped a 15 year old girl
and gang raped her and they they said in
court it was to celebrate eat could you
imagine a Christians celebrating Easter
by kidnapping a Muslim child and gang
rape have a very long history of
horrendous crimes and not justifying it
with their religion not making comments
of their religion not making derogatory
comment and they giving me I mean we we
don't have time to go into that but
there are plenty of historic examples of
that I want to ask you about this
specific
case the grooming case that you got
yourself in tangled with that was indeed
an example of an ethnic gang
specializing in sexual predation the
court that court delivered or resulted
in very very harsh sentences and I think
the defendants were collectively
sentenced to over 220 years in prison
not all of them one of them's in
Pakistan because they let him the day or
the day they put me in jail but they let
the rapist by enlarge the court to
recognize that it was indeed a campaign
of rape against teenage girls do you
think justice was served in that case
justice will be served if there if many
of them who hold dual nationality are
deported when they gaol of prison I
formerly English defense need to
highlight these sorts of issues it was a
total cover up the British establishment
the British press were involved the the
journalist who was given an award for
exposing this in 2011 has admitted that
he knew about it seven years prior
everyone in our British establishment in
Britain Lee has facilitated and allowed
our daughters to be raped
through the fear of political crap mr.
Robin said we have to take a very short
break now okay we'll be back in just a
few moments stay tuned
[Music]
welcome back to worlds apart with
British activist Tony Robinson
mr. Robinson said before they break you
we're talking about this culture of
silencing and I think in many countries
the authorities do on the report those
cases specifically out of fear of
encouraging ethnic hatred and that all
religious hatred that happens in Russia
as well and I know for a fact that you
haven't been convicted of a hate crime
but a lot of your followers have crossed
that line
and took out their anger or frustration
and people who did nothing wrong
does it bother you a lot of my followers
some of your father's and it would you
say that somehow that would be my fault
no I don't think it's your fault but
perhaps I would say that it should have
urged you to be more specific in our
year about a manifesto and in that
manifesto I told them they can attack
people then would it be my fault yeah
but you can also tell them that
committing crimes and they're people who
have nothing to do with that and you
should not take your anger out on those
people I'm not what I'm saying is I have
only ever called for peace oh I've never
called for violence but we do have a
book that calls for violence and
promotes violence and promotes murder
and people were so quick to send me with
what some of my so-called followers may
have done but then when it comes to
Islam and you have a Muslim like who
would beheaded with Lee Rigby and he
hands over 55 verses in the Koran he
says forced him to do it we're still not
allowed to talk about Islam we're not
allowed and as you said I'm banned from
every single social media okay that's
not one I'm banned from YouTube I
haven't got PayPal I'm banned from all
of them we have laws in my country
against inciting hatred I've never been
arrested for a speech I've never even
been questioned about any hate speech or
all or crimes the truth I was removed
from Twitter for stating the fact that
I've told you today Muslim men make up
two percent they represent 84 percent of
convictions it's a fact anyone can look
it that's not hate speech so what we see
now is the British establishment have
hid these crimes
you said they were under report they're
not been under report they've been
hidden and they hid them and then they
realized because there was such furor on
the streets for
two years when English defensively they
realized they've got to now deal with it
so when they started making arrests and
in fact if you look at the graph of when
these arrests started that in the first
first eleven years before the English
Defence League formed there were eleven
arrests the next year after the English
Defence League formed in that one year
there was a third there was thirty six
arrests for RS seventy two arrests
they've had to do something but the full
cover-up mode that they're still in is
now our last forty nine trials only four
only six have been openly reported on
your main problem is not with a random
person on the street even if he or she
happens to be a Muslim you know totally
I grew up in Luton Town some of the best
people I've met in my life um so your
main beef with is with the British
authorities who are turning a blind eye
to this issue don't you think that by
focusing on one particular group in this
case Muslims you're making it all too
easy for the British authorities to
dismiss or deflect from a very
legitimate issue that you're raising
that is how the immigration policies are
being structured and the fact that many
people feel that they have no say in how
their policies are being formulated
aren't you playing into their own hands
no I will tell the truth
bluntly told the tree for converting
bluntly telling something or actually
having an impact I've seen over an
window shift I've seen it 10 years ago
people call me an extremist they said I
was lying they even what I proved
tomorrow in my speech in 2010 I told The
Times newspaper that Muslims were taking
children into pedophilia crossed in
prostitution rings with heroin they
called them extraordinary claims
now all those journalists are catching
up and they're reporting on it just as
these reporting is just as you
formulated Muslims are taking children
into pedophilic ring yes they're
starting to it's now common knowledge in
my country which it wasn't ten years ago
people said we were lying okay it's now
even though they're Muslims I mean for
God's sake I'll go through the comments
from their court cases they're Somali
gang they said it was part of their
culture to do this okay
I mean the culture is not the same
another Muslim said he was teaching the
women a lesson for being out and being
uncovered you can take a verse in the
Quran there's a verse in the Koran that
clearly states a woman must cover as to
not be to separate herself
as to not be molested but there are many
other verses that would tell you that
humans and the women have to be treated
in a good way whole life is a proof of
that but your whole life is a proof of a
decent Muslim man that you're with we
tried the majority of them saying it
that's not proof that Islam promotes
that that's not that's not proof that
the Quran promotes values I think you're
extremely cherry-picking us I think
there is actually a substantive issue
here and I think that on that front the
movement that you are representing is
actually contributing to the change just
the the other day there was a Munich
Security Conference a large conference
for NATO countries and they produced the
report called West lessness in which
they identified nationalist aspirations
as the sort of the biggest challenge to
the so-called Western project and they
actually suggested that many of those
nationalist aspirations are driven by
the immigration policies and the failure
of the authorities to communicate and to
engage the public effectively on those
issues don't you think that you you you
have actually contributed to that shift
in perspective because I would agree
with you a few years ago nobody would
discuss immigration in detail you would
be accused of being a racist you still
are still of accused a bit well
essentially if you went to the right
school in the UK or you're from the
right class you you're allowed to talk
about if you're from a working-class
background you have accent like I do
you're automatically deemed a racist or
extremist and the reality is that the
towns and cities that that immigration
affects this towns like where we live
this areas when I was born in 1982 we
had one mosque we now have 35 I've
witnessed my whole entire town change
and not for the better
there is less freedom there is more
trouble we feel alienated in our own
communities and the whole time we're
told that diversity is great waste our
daughters are being kidnapped and raped
whilst we have in Britain we have 22,000
Muslims on on a terrorist watch
twenty two thousand three thousand Emma
monitored 24 hours a day seven days a
week
cost a nine billion pound a year so the
questions were asking is if we've
already got all these problems I think
six refugees so far have committed
terrorist attacks in Europe why are we
still you had the choice yes how would
you deal with that issue because UK
certainly I mean many of your Muslim
neighbors are British citizens like
yourself yeah what would you change to
make your society a bit more mutual
itself great I've said in my hometown we
have every form of immigration
my mother was an Irish immigrant to the
UK we have serious violence right do you
know that terrorism yeah yes but as you
said Irish violence if it was Catholic
violence the Polish might be involved or
the Italians might go involved you know
violence is not exclusive to any
particular way my mum come to loot and
they had no blacks no dogs no Irish was
on the doors so I know about
discrimination against people based
based on what other groups do but one
saying is solution Jamaican Bulgarian
Italian all of my friends we have
integration actually works with the
different communities the one section
that does not is the followers of Islam
and I'd say that's pretty much because
we have 35 mosques many of them funded
by Pakistan among many of them funded by
Saudi Arabia we we shouldn't take any
medical problem you understand that
that's not a religious problem you're
absolutely right this country for
example we also have as I said you
before the recording they have a large
Muslim population but the state does not
allow the Sahara money to fund their
mosque
neither are Qatari monies allowed here
and that's done specifically to protect
the local version of Islam from foreign
influences we and that's a political
problem or what do ordinary Muslims have
to do with that but now it's a religion
well yeah and ninety percent the Imams
can't speak English but when you're all
about say in one bar of London we have
32 bars of London in one bar of London
and this these children not nine years
old were married in Sharia cause in the
mosques okay so that's to do with the
Imam their back their Marion children
which is against British law their
Marion children some of the
and I'll read this tomorrow this isn't
from my view this is from a women's
rights Kurdish women's watch you have to
throw that not that again not at the
random Muslim at the feet of the British
government for allowing that to happen
and the promotion of child marriage
under Islam and the promotion of
pedophilia under Islam it's easy and the
British government I'll do later the
British government for allowing it to
happen I lay the British government the
most recent terrorist the most recent
terrorist who've just come out who
committed an attack recently they knew
he was going to do it they were
following him at the time and he still
got to stab two people are prisons in
the UK I like Isis training camps I've
been in ok they have taken over our
prison system and they're radicalizing
totally radicalized an eight hundred a
year come out according to our security
services right mr. Robinson you
understand that if you continue fuming
about Islam nothing is going to change
and it's already changing what is
already saying if you look at the
biggest populist parties across Europe
they're all human about Islam if you
look at is one thing but actual change
is another speaking of which I know that
a few days ago the British government
has come up with a new immigration plan
based on various points which
essentially would close the door to an
skilled migrants who do not speak
English up to a certain level do you
think that plan goes far enough to
address some of the problems that you're
concerned about personally no I think
it's a great plan because anyone who's
come into our country should benefit our
country not come to our country and
drain it and the only people who should
be allowed in should also be able to
integrate in assimilate and what we've
seen you've seen so Angela Merkel said
that multiculturalism has failed David
Maher David Cameron said mantra cultures
and it's like I just said that it
succeeded in of Muslims I'm about to say
that yeah that is a weak and cowardly
way of saying Islam has failed because
the reality is the Sikh community the
Hindu community the Jewish community the
Polish the Bulgarians how hard is it for
a Russian person to come to the UK it's
very easy for Pakistanis Somalis Afghan
YZ Iraqis we'd much rather have
immigration which I think that when the
Polish immigration come in my hometown
of Luton I remember thinking how great
it was because all of a sudden we had
people who are culturally as same as us
hard-working family values the family
value system in our country has been
purposely target and broken down the
attack on Christianity which we see I
ever see our Christian leaders we talk
about the Church of England a question
if many of them even believe in Jesus
Christ or whether they're using it for
their own globalist okay you know
they're they're Muslims are still pretty
strong on Family Values I mean they're
there I know they are in fact I went
just last week to meet with some Muslims
there's a Muslim is a protesting outside
a school in the UK because they're now
teaching from the age of six their boys
can be goes and girls can be boys and
they're getting transgender they could
be exactly I mean Russia is one example
of where we have a pretty good
relationship between the various sakes I
mean is that not an argument for you to
actually reframe your you know your
campaign not being anti Islam but more
being anti-immigration or anti stupid
immigration Islam is a friend Islam is
incompatible with Western democracy and
freedom if someone takes Islam its
literal word
it's literal word everybody takes by the
Bible as a literal worth it we'll get
into the same type of if someone wants
to live as Jesus lived are they gonna
kill anyone because Muhammad murdered
Mohammed raped so if someone believes
Mohammed is the moral compass for them
and they believe he is perfect
well he married Aisha when she was six
and here and he raped her when she was
nine so that's a problem okay and to say
it stand to speak openly and freely
about it shouldn't be a crime or we
shouldn't be attacked for it people want
to kill you most of the most of you I'm
nan fees by the way but most religious
people do not take their scriptures
literally these days most but then 20%
are Islamist ideology that's a small
army I promise you're an honor to
broadcast and this is what I'm going to
give you so that's why we have to live
it there thank you very much for having
over no thank you
well and thank you for watching hope to
see you again next Sunday on worlds
apart
[Music]